yes the health district says more people
are traveling for the holidays this year
and with the omicron variants spreading
it's important to get your booster shot
sooner rather than later they say the
vaccine is your next line of protection
as you gather with friends and family
that you may have not seen for a while i
came to get my booster shot as many
families are making last minute holiday
preparations health district officials
hope a booster shot is on that to-do
list i have illnesses myself
and i'm trying to protect myself and my
great-grandbabies and that's the best
thing for me to do is to get the shot
juanita richard is one of many who got
their third vaccine at the southern
nevada health district today many said
they wanted to keep their out of town
guests safe everybody needs to do this
to protect yourself and protect your
loved ones because it's important to
live on friday the cdc expanded its
booster shot recommendation for everyone
16 years and older the southern nevada
health district says those planning to
get the booster before the holidays need
to do it as soon as possible it starts
working right away but it doesn't really
get its full potential for two weeks so
you really want to get it now i mean
it's helpful to get some
protection from the vaccine so any time
is good but
it's time although it's now past the
two-week threshold for christmas the
health district says it's good they're
still seeing an increase in vaccinations
and testing ahead of the holidays we
like to do our new year's parties so
it's very important then too and you may
be with people that are not part of your
family and you really don't know you
know their health conditions so it's
also important to protect those that the
vaccine may not work as well
there are still many booster
appointments available at major
pharmacies all the way up to christmas
cvs says in the last few weeks they've
increased availability and they're
continuing to hire and train new
employees to administer those shots
brian